بؤره افيتار الاستيطانيه جنوبيه نابلس هي
العنوان الاحدث الذي يستخدمه اليمين
الاسرائيلي الديني المتطرف في جهوده
الراميه الى شرعنه المزيد من البؤر
الاستيطانيه المقامه على اراض فلسطينيه في
القانون الدولي جميع المستوطنات التي تقام
على اراضي محتله غير شرعيه لكن في المفهوم
الاسرائيلي البؤر الاستيطانيه غير الشرعيه
تعني اي تجمع استيطاني يشيد في الضفه
الغربيه دون قرار رسمي او موافقه من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ودون تخصيص اي ارض او
تحديد حدود بلديه قد يكون التجمع عباره عن
خيمه ينصبها مستوطن او منشاه متنقله يتم
وضعها على ارض فلسطينيه بعد ان يستولي
المستوطنون عليها وعاده ما تشكل هذه البؤر
اما توسعه لمستوطنه
قائمه او اساسا لبناء مستوطنه جديده
لا تتوفر ارقام دقيقه عن البؤر
الاستيطانيه لكن صورا جويه ما بين عامي 97
و 2021
تشير الى تاسيس
2343 بؤره استيطانيه في الضفه الغربيه
وقد انتشرت هذه البؤر في محافظات الضفه
الغربيه دون استثناء لكن العدد الاكبر
يتركز في رام الله والبير ونابلس والخليل
حيث ينتشر على اراضيها مجتمعه حوالي
64% من البؤر وتشير التقديرات الى وجود
قرابه
من البؤر الاستيطانيه ماهوله اي
83% من البؤر الاستيطانيه بينما تحولت 81
من هذه البؤر او هي قيد التحول الى احياء
تابعه لمستوطنات قائمه او مستوطنات مستقله